hey guys I'm Ryan right and I'm Jerry
and I'm Dan cyber and we're gonna watch
the trailer today for Tekken 7 oh [ __ ]
oh now if there's one game I could say I
really love it's Tekken yeah man we we
we threw down as he took him down Tekken
Tag Tournament yeah [ __ ] was the bomb or
wrong and eddy gordo was my jam raagh
definitely my jam for sure oh yeah
wrong was the [ __ ] and then we were kids
we tried to make a Tekken movie and it
fell apart I fell apart terribly
terribly as a bad day ah Dan wasn't
there unfortunate and he should have
been even what the [ __ ] could have fixed
everything you could fix everything this
is your fault
well boy I hope you I was needed
elsewhere I heard you're happy though I
mean we missed out on making some do you
think do you think I'm happy about
missing out on the Tekken movie we had
the greatest Tekken movie in mind that
would have been filmed in the Studio
City Park yeah you ruined everything
it even included a vague parody of the
snake ohms commercial no wait
snack ups we're still ha ha ha ha so we
call them Tekken's oh my god that's
amazing
damn it I missed this what's wrong with
me I was gonna play Haram no I was gonna
play who was I gonna play
you're gonna play gin dude focus Jim was
the main character yeah that's right
make myself the lead all right I'm sure
like painted a shirt I cut the sleeves
off with like a bull skull oh yeah you
went on laude see and I was at the wrong
part yeah guys with the wrong article I
had I had a bunch of people agree to be
in this and they all went to a park and
I went to the wrong Park like two hours
wondering where everyone what's and his
mom got so mad at my dad ha ha ha ah
good tide and second the day anyway that
puts me in the mood to watch Tekken oh
and I play Tekken with you for the first
time in years yeah I deny elated you
everybody kicked my ass in halo that's
all that matters yeah it's me only
association I have with halo is getting
my ass kicked
number one I ever played halo with was
like come join us for multiplayer even
though we do this all the time and
you've never played before yeah yeah
that's exactly how it was yeah
like a sasquatch
you're here
that miss me the time has come fine stop
I must stop hey Hachi by now I'm sure
hey Hachi has real trousers
mother
there's the last one come on
because Jin and I mean Kazuya and
Heihachi I've been having that fight for
many years now
ah the gun rehan Ryo for thanks I'm just
so familiar with that it's ridiculous
just how familiar I am with that yeah um
great job anyway I'm second story is
still pretty much the same except for
yeah you girl oh yeah
Tekken game seems like it's kind of
similar to the last one come on Magwitch
was like you get tagged yeah but I think
Tekken they do have really cool stories
in there you get glimpses of them in the
movie clips but if you like go aligner
and read the stories about them yeah
you're like this is really cool stories
and then even the Tekken animated movie
was pretty true to the stories but then
they made her a live-action one in
America that was horrible ah was in
America I was a Korean production there
was a Korean one and then they made one
that was an American film that starred
the guy played hey Hachi was the Kasane
guy who played shang tsung immortal
comment white yeah I gotta look this up
you guys could have prevented that oh no
we should have you mean yes all on us I
mean some might say it's horrible but
honestly to me it's probably the best
the best representation of Tekken I've
ever seen well that's a fundamental
conundrum of cinema is like is it really
impossible to make a good movie out of a
fighting video game hell yeah can you
can you can you what dude I am going to
make the Tekken movie productions back
on I'm saying it could happen in the
future but it seems like a tall order is
honestly I got my I got Mauro vs. Capcom
3 the basis story lines beat a bunch of
dudes fight uh Galactica's you can't do
like Marvel vs. Capcom but you could do
like a good Street Fighter movie and
they proved that with Street Fighter
with jean-claude Van Damme hands-down
best video game adaptation of her no
Silent Hill I completely disagree that
was probably the worst that in Mortal
Kombat word the two worst hunter
I guess you're doing here oh by the con
oh I got you
I love that people are still gonna take
me seriously yeah there's always one
comment there's like what are you
talking about
yeah [ __ ] queer what's wrong with you
yeah yeah your opinion on movie is
clearly is a denotation of your sexual
yeah to go hand in hand
I just love fighting games because
everyone's resting position is like this
thing with a dualistic code chance yeah
yeah you gotta hop you gotta have the
hoppity hop you got a hit do the Humpty
hump
oh yeah well thanks guys for telling me
that trade of the result if you're new
to the Chanel subscribe here if this
[ __ ] had a Coco Chanel number five
mmm-hmm and Dan has a gaming channel to
that sibert Channel right here you
should start an Indian gaming channel
indie human gene has like review slot
machine I tried to move it together
Texas Hold'em is great Texas I'm gonna
do a walk-through right now have
blackjack who wants to play craps
alright but honestly I give craps like a
four out of Krabs's I mean I still
haven't grasped how to play the game you
control all the knives the controls are
really difficult a responsive yeah yeah
yeah but the Unreal Engine in that
casino the way they put it to you like
there is a naturalistic lighting yeah
yeah and if you it would ragdoll effects
really good get really drunk you just
kind of live well I love how most
casinos are like an open sandbox world
because yes go outside of them yeah and
you can interact with the entire
environment yeah and you can use most
anything as a weapon and the AI are
incredibly like if you if you punch an
old woman like security is like oh yeah
no and they'll figure out your
strategies in real time yeah in real
time and if you gamble long enough
they'll give you free drinks yeah it's
really cool I mean I overall I give the
casino like an F didn't rip it rip it
love it [ __ ] rip business you are
ripping your roof a bro very white
enthralled by the town
it's okay sir just go steady with your
shoutouts buddy dude shoutout tag
tarnish at out Tag Tournament yeah can I
have one two three four five Jenaya
China always get this name wrong
hey Matt is it possible for a shout-out
I just graduated college man dude I want
to feel special but yeah dude
congratulations dude it's awesome that
you're out of college Congrats
do you miss out on all the [ __ ] though
man that you were getting all that [ __ ]
according to the porn there's a lot of
gang bangs there's a lot of orgies
they're just [ __ ] everywhere really at
college and if you're rich Oh true I'll
just get rich yeah just get rich that's
just like college again come in
shout-out to Murray Murray gets an
honorary shout-out for life let me know
your cool image if you [ __ ] up with
take
anyway can i yeah we shout out get a
hell are four hundred times have we yeah
feel like he just graduated college no
I'm excited for him her I know I mean
he's been waiting let's grow we gonna
watch him grow yeah down to what gonna I
majored in probably film probably
YouTube's or must biology yeah it was
clearly one of those did you get a
business degree ah gonna denote
marketing uh-oh communications yeah
Aaron app shout out now that's really
indignantly shut up they said please
Ryan oh please okay okay Lisa please it
sounds like desperation good please Ryan
the exciting your photo Aaron Aaron why
are you so sad bro does something happen
did you not get a shot on a different
channel never hear ya lookin for love
dude what was that other channel will
kick that channels ass we won't let them
bully you around
no MFR I'm calling that other channel
right now and we're gonna have a talk
yeah telephone was it Jeremy Jones
Jeremy Jones wasn't it
Oh Jeremy you son-of-a-bitch
like Cara meet you and comment below let
me know if it is Jeremy Jones thing
Roxie 13 may have a shout-out I love
your videos
bro bro but the awesome work man what
are you doing next one word at a time
one word at a time alright bar next to
all the hot girls you are with man I
wouldn't stop groping them all you know
it's better than hot girls hot guys yeah
so straight minutes a hot again dude I'm
telling you right now we're not going to
let any more girls come on the show only
guys we're gonna play some all the guys
Emery I just I've just a little alarm
that that you you think you wouldn't be
able to help yourself from just
incessantly groping your female co-stars
I mean that's gonna lead you to some
products just look at yourself yes
you're gonna get smacked or sued or
something yeah man it doesn't end well
if you just go around grabbing all the
boob you could find yeah doesn't work no
trust me I don't like going to jail yeah
it's a really uncomfortable experience
we were holding each other for a while
yeah it was comfortable you had your arm
around the back of mine that was
comfortable my goal for this is for
somebody to write I you know what we
will have made it when somebody writes a
fanfiction about us with like overly
flowery use of adjectives ship us please
ship the hell out of us please just do a
slash pick about the real reject it was
raining one night as Ryan Wright left
the movie theater cold and lonely so he
called Jerry on the telephone
how are the trailers suck Jerry they
sucked well I just stepped out of the
shower and I haven't closed my robe yet
said Jerry
huskily dance wings the door open hey
guys what you up to
exactly yeah we have a night now we have
the fan to comment below and give us a
fit I want all the comments to be
fanfictions from now on
yeah just like one paragraph fanfiction
hi Ben cool TV with the real reason
something has gone wrong something has
gone terribly wrong I roll out of
control sorry I'll stop talking no we
can [ __ ]
green drum what this is what happens and
you get the three of us on a couch
together eventually the train of thought
runs off a cliff similar yeah
just like an Abraham Lincoln vampire